what such imagining vaguely has in mind
in the case of this such refuge is the
truth thought which in fact abolish is
that imagining namely that being as such
is not the truth of spirit at all just
as the disposition is itself an original
being which has no part in the activity
of spirit just such a being is the bone
on its side
what merely is without any spiritual
activity is for consciousness a thing
and far from being the essence of
consciousness is rather its opposite and
consciousness is only actual to itself
through the negation and abolition of
such a being from this point of view it
must be regarded as a complete denial of
reason to pass off a bone as the actual
existence of consciousness and it is
passed off as such when it is regarded
as the outer being of spirit for the
outer is just that reality which merely
is it is no you saying that the inner is
only being inferred from the outer and
is something different nor that the
outer is not the inner itself but only
its expression for in the relation of
the two to one another the determination
of the reality that thinks itself and is
in the form of thought does fall on the
side of the inner but on the side of the
outer falls the determination of the
reality which merely is when therefore a
man is told you your inner being are
this kind of person because your skull
bone is constituted in such in such a
way this means nothing else that I
regard a bone as your reality to reply
with to such a judgment with a box on
the ear as in the case of a similar
judgment and physiognomies mentioned
above at first takes away from the soft
parts their importance in position and
proves only that these are no true in
itself are not the reality of spirit the
retort here would strictly speaking have
to go the length of beating in the skull
of anyone making such a judgment in
order to demonstrate in a manner just as
palpable as his wisdom that for a man
is nothing in itself much less his true
reality
in the paragraphs leading up to
paragraph 339 Hagel has drawn a strong
distinction between what can be imagined
and he thinks that phrenology and
physiognomies really worked within the
realm of the imagination and what can be
thought and thought in a more strict
rigorous manner what's going to actually
provide us with science or visum shocked
and he criticized a subterfuge sort of
you know contradictory status that that
physiognomies and phrenology were
arriving at based on this this
distinction between imagination and
thought so he says what we're losing
sight of is something that that will
actually abolish this imagining and on
the one side we have I should have put
over here on the one side we have being
or design what it is that we've seen
that spirit is not down that doesn't
mean that spirit doesn't exist but
spirit doesn't have the being that is
just a being you might say and so he
says that what's been lost sight of is
that that being is such is not the truth
of spirit at all what does that mean
well among other things you cannot
reduce what Hegel is calling spirit
Geist mind you cannot reduce this merely
to something that could be an object for
the mind that is a being which then can
be grasped however you want to put it by
the intellect by the mind you know
written down represented somewhere maybe
it digitized and all that sort of stuff
that we do today none of these are going
to be adequate to what is going on a
spirit in part because spirits is not
only something to be thought it's also
the thing that's
the thinking when it's trying to
conceptualize itself and so there's
always going to be some you might say
not just indeterminacy but if it an over
determination there that the logic of
being simply is not adequate to so this
is a larger point than just about
phrenology or or physiognomies so he
goes on returning back to those though
he says what merely is without any
spiritual activity is for consciousness
a a thing that's what it means to be a
thing it doesn't have any agency it
doesn't have any interior reflectiveness
of its own so he says far from being the
essence of consciousness is rather its
opposite and this is an interesting
point to dwell on we see all sorts of
interesting attempts throughout the
history of philosophy and particularly
once psychology emerges as its own
discipline to try to say we could reduce
consciousness or the objects of
consciousness our ideas or our
experiences or something like that so
something that we can figure as just
being or types of beings Hegel is
resisting that there there won't be any
adequate explanation that isn't already
you might say a thinking explanation
which means that it's not something that
can be purely externalized put into a
text book and then just learned right or
turn into algorithms which then could be
programmed into a computer that's not to
say that perhaps we couldn't create
artificial intelligence or something
along those lines but that's not going
to be the way that artificial
intelligence actually ends up happening
they'll have to be something else going
on so he goes on and he says from this
point of view it must be regarded as a
complete denial of reason to pass off a
bone as the actual existence of
consciousness
so if reason was as we're starting to
come to a close now with this entire
section
if reason is what happens after
self-consciousness goes through all this
dialectical processes and consciousness
realizes that this entire plenum of
being is for it because it can extend
itself into the intelligibility that's
there and we saw that that can be quite
complex well that means that if reason
is going to be satisfied it cannot
really be satisfied by being given an
explanation of consciousness of spirit
of whatever you like in terms of
something that's purely physical
something that's manifest just as a
thing so he goes on and he says look you
can't pass off a bone like the scholars
spirit and it doesn't work when you talk
about this outer and inner stuff he says
there's no use saying that the outer the
inner is only being inferred from the
outer and is something different because
you're not really saying that it's
something different anyway it may be
something different in that that's you
know goop inside your head you know your
brain cells but you're saying that it
has the same configuration as something
that you're observing externally so he
says nor that the outer is not the inner
itself but only its expression that's
not going to work and here's where it
gets very interesting so he said in the
relation of the two to one another the
to the determination of the reality that
thinks itself and is in the form of
thought right it's a reality that thinks
itself that is thought the German for
that is that this is a reality that is
ich denke ndon and get docked and and
that's a little bit stronger than than
miller's formulation here it literally
thinks itself and is thought in the
process it's not just thought as the you
know substantive of the activity like a
Faculty of thinking it is thought that's
a past participle there it has been
thought it is you might say what it
thinks itself to be
and takes into account that very process
of thinking itself to be something
totally different than the you know
purely objective existence of the skull
right and this is where we we get to
very interesting observations and
Hegel's not really making here but I
want to give us some pause when we think
about the brain and then trying to
reduce consciousness to just brain
States or something like that Hegel
might actually be receptive to reduction
of consciousness to brain states but he
would say yeah the brain is way more
complicated than a lot of you think it
is because you're treating it as if it's
just something like the skull or like a
computer or like and we can add you know
whatever other metaphors we like in here
and not looking at it in its own respect
as the locus we're thinking about its
own self does in fact take place right
if you can't have that reflexive part of
it and that's you know there have to be
very smart to have that sort of
reflexivity going on it's necessary to
our ordinary existence and that's just
for thinking about yourself that's
didn't even like bringing in other
people the other that we've talked about
in the self-consciousness section that
we're going to talk about here the other
that's necessary for spirit all of that
is mediated for Hegel through the brain
which means that the brain can't be
something like the skull so he goes on
Laney says all of us this is realization
on the side of the outer falls the
determination of the reality which
merely is right so we've got something
super interesting and dynamic going on
here over here we got bones and bones
are cool but öhlins are just bones they
could have been made out of metal so the
bone they have certain configurations
great that that's about it so he says
when therefore a man is told you your
inner being are this kind of person
because your skull bone does constitute
in such in such a way this means nothing
else then there's a reduction going on
here I'm regard a
own as your reality I regard a bone as
who and what you are I'm gonna forget
the fact that you're a thinking being
not just a being that thinks about other
stuff but a being that thinks about
itself and thereby modifies itself in
the process but I ignore all that stuff
and say you're you're this bump you're
the criminal bump you're the poet bump
you're the whatever bump you're the chef
bump you're the military commander bump
you're the good friend bump you're the
bad friend bump pick whatever you want
and Hagel says you know the appropriate
reaction to this earlier he said the
appropriate reaction is to punch thing a
guy in the side of the head give him a
box on the ear right or you can smack
him I suppose here he says you know if
you really wanted to take that seriously
you would need something that would go
in and and hit him so hard it would
modify the skull because somebody who
thinks that all we are walking skulls
that's the only way to reach somebody
like that that's essentially what he's
what he's saying here and his joking
around a little bit so he says the
retort here would strictly speaking have
to go the length of beating in the skull
of anyone making such a judgment in
order to demonstrate in a manner just as
palpable as his wisdom that for a man a
bone is nothing in itself still less his
true reality we are in fact our bodies
right we are our skulls we're sure not
just our skulls and our skulls are not
the Royal Road or the you know key or
anything whatever metaphor you want to
use for deciphering what is actually
going on in our individuality and in our
processes of thinking and action
the crude instinctive self-conscious
reason will reject out of hand such a
science of phrenology this other
observational instinct of self-conscious
reason which having attained - a glimpse
of the cognitive process has grasped at
unintelligently in a way that takes the
outer to be the expression of the inner
but the worse the conception the less
sometimes does it occur to one where in
its badness specifically lies and the
harder it is to analyze it for a
conception is said to be worse the purer
and emptier the abstraction which is
taken to be its essence
but the antithesis we are here concerned
with has for its sides the individuality
that is conscious of itself and the
abstraction of externality that has
become wholly a thing that inner being
of spirit grasp does affixed non
spiritual being opposed to such a being
but reason in its role of observer
having reached thus far seems also to
have reached its peak at which point it
must abandon itself and do it right
about turn for only what is wholly bad
is implicitly charged with the immediate
necessity of changing round into its
opposite just so it may be said of the
Jewish people that it is precisely
because they stand before the portal
portal of salvation that they are and
have been the most reprobate and
rejected what that people should be in
and for itself this essential nature of
its own self is not explicitly present
to it on the contrary it places it
beyond itself by this alienation it
creates for itself the possibility of a
higher existence if only it could take
back again into itself its alienated
object then if then if it hadn't
remained undisturbed within the
immediacy of being because spirit is all
the greater the greater the opposition
from which it is returned into itself
but it creates this opposition for
itself by setting aside its immediate
unity and by alienating its being for
self however if such a consciousness
does not reflect on itself the
intermediate position or middle term
which it occupies is an unhappy void
since what should fill and fulfill it
has been turned into a fixed extreme
thus it
is that this final stage of reason in
its observational role is its worst and
this is why its reversal becomes a
necessity
one of the lessons that we can draw from
paragraph 340 which Hegel is not
completely spelling out at this point is
that phrenology and physiognomies and
the sort of mindset and approach and
assumptions that have gone along with
them are not a total loss unless we
assume them to be the final word on
things in which case we wind up with
what he was talking about at the end
this middle term that doesn't get us
anywhere and this is a big loss for us
right but if we understand what has been
going on if we step back a little bit as
phenomenologist and think about what's
been going on in this process of
examining the the way in which
consciousness would use these these
pseudo Sciences to try to make sense out
of its own individuality and thereby
also the individuality of other people
then we have the sort of we might call
it archetypal Hegelian progression that
goes on and before people start you know
getting too much you know into the
framework of thesis antithesis synthesis
let's say two things right off the bat
one is that Hegel does point out at
antithesis but it's not an antithesis of
this term to this this term rather this
term itself is finding out that there's
an antithesis there and you can say well
okay that's that's an antithesis over
here then we've got antithesis in two
different ways the second thing to say
is that Hegel in the phenomenology
doesn't talk about thesis antithesis
synthesis instead what he talks about
much more often is a triadic movement
but it's a triadic movement first of the
in itself or have a starting point then
of an estrangement or alienation and
rendang you know - it's a sort of a
technical term and then there's some
sort of reconciliation of bringing
things back together
Kizuna which which occurs and this is
only being sketched out here it's not
really being elaborated that's going to
happen in the paragraphs yet to come
so let's let's run our way through what
he's saying no he says this crude
instinct of self conscious reason is
going to reject out of hand any sort of
science of phrenology the way that we've
been sketching it out so far this other
observational instinctive self conscious
reason which having attained to a
glimpse of the cognitive process has
grasped it unintelligently in a way that
takes the outer to be the expression of
the inner so what we have is reason able
to realize that one of the ways that it
wanted to go about its its task and this
hand to happen Hegel thinks historically
because it's necessary to try things out
it's necessary to try to follow the
instinct of reason and it you know we
saw a permutation after permutation
after permutation of the outer is the
expression of the inner attempted to you
know be provided as laws we saw that it
just doesn't work out like that
and then what did we see after that he
says the worst the conception the less
sometimes does it occur to one where in
its badness specifically lies and the
harder it is to analyze it now that's a
good point often times we're not able to
see what's wrong with a particular point
of view that we're we're using and seems
to work for us a bit until we have
another perspective to bring to bear on
it and only after we bring that other
perspective to bear can we say oh wow I
was really off I was more off than I
thought I was the perspective that I had
wasn't just wrong in this one way that
this other perspective fixes it was
wrong in this way and this way and this
way and this this one over here blind
me too how screwed up everything else
was that's very typical that happens all
the time in any sort of development I
think that's a really important general
point niggle is bringing up here one
that applies just as much to technical
processes as it does to virtue ethics as
it does to advances in music I mean we
can talk about things so we're blue in
the face about about those sorts of
examples so he says a conception is said
to be worse what makes it worse the pure
and empty or the abstraction which is
taken to be its essence now notice that
for a lot of philosophers the pure and
more abstract it is the better it is now
for hegel hegel thinks if we want to
hear Hegel let me let me preface this
this is sort of an aside here Hegel is
placing himself within a long loose
tradition of philosophers who think that
you don't do philosophy well by getting
away from reality that you have to take
in you don't just you know come up with
in a bunch of ideas and then press them
on to reality and say so much the worse
for reality you've got to take your cues
from reality who would that include
Aristotle for one right in the Middle
Ages Thomas Aquinas would be another
great example in the early modern period
who might you look - I would say Blaise
Pascal is is a great example of that
sort of thing and finally you know in
the the you know 19th century we have we
have Hegel on the scene saying you got
to take account of everything and that's
actually where the Hegelian system shows
its weaknesses it's not in you know what
it does well it's where it has has
sometimes failed to go as far as it
could in grasping concrete individuality
as Kierkegaard's complaint in grasping
what's going on in material economic
processes that's Mark's complaint you
know in making sense out of what's
really happening and
terms of the individual and
enlightenment and and religion that's
Maurice blown Dells point we can go on
and on and on but all of those are
working off of a Hegel who went about as
far as that you can go with this in part
because he rejected pure empty
abstraction he said that's just a
starting point
that's not where philosophy ought to
remain so where do we go from there he
says the antithesis we are here
concerned with has for its sides the
individuality that's conscious of itself
that's what we're trying to make sense
of that's what the the instinctive
reason really wants to grasp because
it's important how do we make sense out
of individuality we saw it earlier we
have these laws of thought and you know
they're nice but we want to make sense
of individuals and how they arrived at
their self determining decisions and how
they express themselves and and we've
been doing this like looking at skulls
and bodily shapes so the individual
conscious of itself and the thing or you
like spirit and the skull right so he
goes on and he says the inner being of
spirit grasped is a fixed non spiritual
being opposed to such a being that's
what the thing is it's something that is
coming from spirit turning against
spirit and trying to be made into a
replacement of it so he says reason in
its role of observer having reached thus
far also seems to reach its peak so it's
right here and then we had the
antithesis or the estrangement coming
about the alienation reason if it's been
paying attention about what's going on
realizes oh I got myself into quite a
pickle this looks like an opera a place
where I'm not going to get out of and it
could just you know then lapse um to
skepticism couldn't so he goes on and he
says at this point it has to abandoned
itself
do it right about turn four only what is
wholly bad is implicitly charged with
the immediate necessity of changing
round into its opposite and that's part
of what's gonna happen here it realizes
oh I wanted to have this unifying
conception of things now I'm stuck with
this you know distinction here that I'm
not really able to make sense of even
worse I'm this thing here trying to make
sense of this and this at the same time
and now Eagle has this comparison to the
Jewish people you know if you think
about what he's trying to say here by by
way of comparison so in Christian
doctrine and this is you know something
that is essentially reflected in Jewish
doctrine and coming out of it the Jews
are the people who God has the highest
expectations of and precisely because
they are like he says that the portal of
salvation when they screw up it's a big
deal they really really screw it up and
their fault you know if you just read
the Old Testament some time particularly
read kings and chronicles yeah well
actually read judges you read other
stuff too and you're gonna see that
there never is a case where God is like
totally satisfied with the the
Israelites or you know the the Judean
czar whoever because they're all they're
always like one step away from totally
screwing it up
and why is that the case it's because
unlike all the other people surrounding
them they are the chosen ones they're
where progress is supposed to be
happening so if the Canaanites want to
do their nature religion and you know
engage in their Wars and oppress their
neighbors and do all this sort of stuff
that's you know it's not good nobody's
saying that that is that's fine and they
do have you know according to the
natural law they should know what
they're doing what they're not they're
not the ones who had a you know sort of
revelation given
a direct connection and so he says you
know the by alienation by this
alienation it creates for itself the
possibility of a higher existence if
only it could take back into itself its
alienated object then and if it had
remained undisturbed within the
immediacy of being so what Hegel is
talking about here is this this hay
galleon three-step that happens of
starting-point estrangement realization
that something is being lost something
is being threatened something as being
becoming you know problematic and then
some sort of reconciliation that takes
back what was there in the first place
but transforms it in the process this is
our fable
this is sublation this is what's going
on and he says here we go spirit is all
the greater the greater the opposition
from which it is returned into itself so
it's not as if you can skip this step
and just jump right past it into the
reconciliation this is one of the key
points of the Hegelian dialectic this is
the the dark night right that you have
to pass through and and lacking that
there can't be this this brilliant dawn
on the other side so he says it creates
the opposition for itself by setting
aside its immediate unity and alienating
its being for self but there's there's a
danger here if such a consciousness he
says does not reflect upon itself it's
not going to get over here it's gonna
remain oscillating back and forth
between these two in what in other
places Hegel calls a bad infinity
it's never gonna arrive at the finish
point self-consciousness is required for
that reflection upon itself he says if
it doesn't do that the intermediate
position or middle term which it
occupies is an unhappy void since what
should fill and fulfill it has been
turned into a thick
extreme again the oscillation back and
forth he says that thus it is that this
final stage of reason in its
observational role is its worst and this
is why its reversal becomes a necessity
so what's going on here in the critique
of for now phrenology and and
physiognomies and and really a critique
that Hegel could levy against anything
similarly worked out in our own time or
in the future is like he said this
instinctive self-conscious reason that
has found that it went into a blind
alley and now we have to figure out how
to get past that and get to someplace
where there's some some paths ahead
for a survey of the series of relations
considered so far which constitute the
content and object of observation shows
that in their first form that is in the
observation of the relations of
inorganic nature sensuous being is
already lost to view the moments of
their relations present themselves as
pure abstractions and as simple notions
which should be firmly tied to the
existence of things an existence however
which gets lost so that the moment
demonstrates itself to be a pure moment
and a universal this free process which
is complete within itself retains the
significance of something objective but
now appears as a unitary being in the
process of the inorganic this unitary
being is the non-existent inner but the
process existing as a unitary being is
the organism the unitary being qua of
being for self or negative being stands
and antithesis to the universal draws
away from it and remains free for itself
so that the notion being realized only
in the element of absolute singleness in
isolation does not find an organic
existence it's true expression that is
to be present as a universal but remains
an outer or what is the same thing an
inner of organic nature the organic
process is only implicitly free but is
not explicitly free for itself the being
for self of its freedom appears in
purpose and exists as another being as a
wisdom that is conscious of itself and
is outside of the process reason in the
role of observer thus turns to this
wisdom turns to spirit to the notion
existing as a universality or to purpose
existing as purpose and henceforth the
object before it is its own essence
now we see this 3-part movement working
again as Hegel summarizes some of the
previous developments in paragraph 341
beginning with observation of inorganic
nature and that moving to observation of
the organism and finally looking at what
the culmination actually not the
culmination yet because that's going to
come in in in later sections but the
culmination at least here of the
observation of individuality that's been
going on in the last two sections the
the short section that we had prior to
this and then in this entire section of
the phrenology and physiognomies right
so we have this development of the in
itself and some sort of estrangement
alienation if you like and then friend
them and then some sort of hopeful
reconciliation now there is a
reconciliation that's taking place
because we're moving through the
phenomenology but it's quite possible
for somebody to get stuck and never make
any progress beyond that and what Hegel
says is is we begin in this this survey
he says we begin with observation of the
relations of inorganic nature right in
doing so I'm gonna sort of skip through
this a little bit he says that what we
ultimately end up focusing on is the
universal there really is no interior
already as such that would be opposed to
exterior already in any meaningful way
for inorganic nature it's only when we
get to the organism that the inner
begins to matter because the the inner
core
you know minerals will just cut them
open and break them down and we can see
what we want so that's where we began
and and we saw that the universal it is
really important for that right and he
says that that you know we have simple
notions which should be firmly tied to
the existence of things but the
existence gets lost and the movement
demonstrates itself to
the pure movement and a universal this
is the free process which is complete
within itself retains the significance
of something objective but now appears
as a unitary being in the process of the
inorganic this unitary being is the
non-existent inner but the process
existing is unity as a unitary being is
the organism and we saw we had all these
discussions about teleology and life and
purpose and it was very very interesting
wasn't it see how it goes beyond
observation of organic nature and to see
that these notions that that we often
take for granted as we're doing
philosophical biology or even
anthropology are a bit little there a
little bit murkier than we we grant them
to be sometimes we think we've got them
down more and what was the ultimate
clash that's going on there it's the
individual versus the universal he says
the unitary being qua a being for self
or negative being stands in antithesis
in opposition to the universal draws
away from it and remains free for itself
so now the notion which is what we're
looking for the entire time to be
graphed right
being realized only in the elements of
absolute singleness does not find an
organic existence it's true expression
what is it's true expression to be
present as a universal but not to be
present as as a universal in this way to
be present as a universal in another way
as a concrete universal as Hegel will
say at different points not explicitly
in this paragraph but but at different
points so now he goes on and he says the
organic process is only implicitly free
right there's something we've seen this
before life does not as Hegel says have
a history not as life itself it's only
when life is transformed into something
more than mere life into spirits into
the notion or at least trying to get
there
right not necessarily fully there but
it's only when life transcends life that
it really matters that things stick that
that we have something that could be a
universal and that is what's supposed to
be happening in this observation of
individuality
he says ultimately
we're finding that the being for self of
its freedom what the whose freedom the
individual the being for self of its
freedom appears in purpose in back now
we've saw that already introduced here
and talking about organisms organisms
have Zach an end a purpose for
themselves right they become their own
purpose right at a certain point in
Hegel's examination but it's when we can
frame to ourselves purposes that we can
talk about with other people talk about
with ourselves reflect upon perhaps
change perhaps modify over time that we
can act upon or refrain from it's that
which takes us beyond the realm of mere
biology in life or even natural history
and into determinately human history so
he says what we've got going on here the
being force off of its freedom appears
in purpose and exists as another being a
wisdom that is conscious of itself and
is outside of the process now that's
going to happen way at the end right but
Hegel's hinting at what's going on
already here in this paragraph
so he says reason in the role of
observer thus turns to this wisdom it's
sort of like it's citing it from a
lighthouse far far away right and it
turns to spirit it turns to the notion
existing as a universality or purpose
existing as purpose
Zek exist that ended Zack as Hegel says
and henceforth the object before it is
its own
where are we going we're getting to the
point and I want to give too much away
at this point but it's very interesting
we're getting the point where what's
going to be happening is reason or the
rational being focusing upon itself no
longer just you know looking at its
bones or stuff like that
but looking at what it does what it
thinks about itself how it connects
itself with other human beings in its
culture what sense it makes of itself
what it has to say about itself and that
is going to be where the development is
going to take place in the sections yet
to come
you